good morning everyone great to see you
and great to be here at Chelmsford
Boxing Club and I used to be actually
involved in a boys and girls club in the
past and I know what an incredible job
you guys do to provide services for
young people so thank you for doing that
makes a huge huge difference as I've
seen myself now at the beginning of the
year I set out some priorities and I
always said that your priorities and my
priorities are the government's
priorities and they're pretty simple and
they're behind me it's the heart of
inflation grow the economy reduce debt
cut waiting list and to stop the boats
that's what we're busy getting on doing
and I'm really confident that over the
course of this year you are going to see
that we are delivering for you and for
everyone else on those five priorities
but alongside that I also want to make
sure that we have a country where all of
us our families our kids are growing up
in strong communities communities that
feel safe communities that are thriving
communities that we offer feel proud to
call home
from communities are built on values and
in fact the most important rule that we
teach our kids is the Golden Rule right
it's about respect it's about treating
others in the way that you would like to
be treated back and unfortunately as
Vicky was just talking about right there
is a small minority of people who break
that Golden Rule and cause disruption
and disorder in their communities and
you know what I'm talking about you've
all seen it
about gangs Gathering being disruptive
being drunk being disorderly people
littering graffiting fly tipping and
that's not it's not okay right it's not
okay for a oh
experience it for us as families to not
be able to walk around freely in our
communities avoid Parks or high streets
of particular times of the day you know
that's not the type of communities that
you want it's not the type of country
that we are and that's why it's
important that we do something about it
now of course we're putting 20 000 more
police officers on the street and we're
making great progress on that record
numbers here in in Essex uh but that you
know that's great but we really want to
focus specifically on anti-social
behavior and that's what today's about
and you've got a copy of our new action
plan on your chairs but there's gonna
just highlight what's in there for you
there are kind of three buckets of it
the first is that we need to make sure
that we give anti-social Behavior the
urgency
that this subject deserves so what we're
going to do is use far more hot spot
policing where we make sure that our
police Target the areas that are of most
concern it's been proven to work in lots
of different places and we're going to
have more use of what's called immediate
justice so that those people who are
behaving irresponsibly and poorly will
have to repair the damage they're
causing clear up the mess that they've
made within days of that having been
caught so that Justice can be seen to be
done that's what media Justice is about
so that's about treating ASB with the
urgency it demands the next thing is to
have a zero tolerance approach to all
forms of anti-social behavior and
especially I'm talking about drugs so
what we're going to do is Ban nitrous
oxide because I think all of us for far
too long have had to walk through places
or the canisters and all the rest of it
and that's not acceptable so we're going
to ban nitrous oxide and we're also
going to expand the power of the police
to do drug testing on a rest for far
more crimes and far more drugs and
tackle the scourge of drugs and then the
third thing in the plan is to give the
police and local authorities the tools
and the powers they need to combat
anti-social Behavior so we're
significantly increasing in some cases
doubling the fines that local
authorities councils can charge for
things like fly tipping littering
graffiti we're making it easier to evict
anti-social tenants
and we're investing more money in the
provision of Youth Services like this a
million extra hours for youth clubs to
provide other things for young people to
do and investing in communities to build
more parks and green spaces which are
shown to have a real impact on people's
well-being so that is the plan there's a
lot more in there but that's a plan in a
nutshell got immediate Justice Hot Spot
policing a ban on nitrous oxide more
drug testing and more investment in
Youth Services more investment in green
spaces and more powers for local
councils because this is really
important I know it's important to you
and your families is important to me and
the government and this plan is how we
are going to Stamp Out anti-social
Behavior it's how we're going to level
up across our country and most
importantly it's how we're going to
build strong and thriving communities
that we are proud to call home so that
in a nutshell is what we're here to talk
about today thank you very much for your
time
[Applause]
right I'm going to throw it open feel
free to ask me anything you want that's
why I'm here for we should talk about
ASB a bit because that's important in
topical but anything else on your mind
as well I'm here for anything and
everything so I'll throw open and who
wants to go first yes sir
thank you um prime minister your your
expert advisors on drugs say that
criminals from the media I am yeah you
know what we're going to come to your
questions at the end if that's all right
let me do that so I want to try and get
some questions from the audience we've
got plenty of time for media questions
at the end right perfect right so who do
we have we have uh yes sir here
thank you
prime minister how do you go about
reporting me on your social behavior and
shoplifting and if it's the
non-emergency phone number have you ever
tried that non-emergency phone number
it's much frustrating thing in the world
yeah no that is a very good point and
you know one thing when we were putting
this plan together you know what you
just said we heard a lot from people and
you know actually if you look at it
oddly enough police recorded incidents
of antisocial Behavior are down 35 in
the last year or so the last couple of
years so you think gosh we're making
really good progress and actually when
you talk to people what's clear is tons
of it is not going reported because too
many people feel exactly the way that
you do they're like it's too difficult
what's the point and no one would
anything about it right and that's what
we're trying to fix so one thing you'll
see in there is what we're going to roll
out is a new digital tool that it's
going to make it far easier for people
to report antisocial behavior and
actually to be able to do it digitally
and online and then get an update on
what's Happening about it now we're not
going to do that overnight so we're
going to have to build that over the
course this year and roll it out but
it's going to address the problem that
you raised right because it should be
easy when you see something happening it
should be easy for you to say this is
what I've seen this is what's going on
and then have the local Authority in the
police report back on what they've done
about it so that you feel that your
concerns are being listened to yeah is
there it takes seconds for the
antisocial to take place or shoplifting
time you report online it goes to
wherever it's happened they've gone so
what you do then
we've had loads of problems at local
market here
reports to replace
you can set your watch on it every
Saturday afternoon and this Saturday
twice I set the fire alarms off
congruency to all our businesses life
because they've got going investigate
fire along
they reset the fire alarm
then what's a half hour later they've
done it again for this time they've
pressed two fire alarms and there we are
trying to earn a living all right in
these rough times
and all the customers are now gone
and then we we can't do nothing like
it's so frustrating you know I I'll just
at the end of October no look and that's
what I talked about at the beginning
about having high streets and town
centers that are thriving right because
you're trying to work hard and run a
business people want to come and do
their shopping and if it's not safe if
it doesn't feel safe none of that's
going to happen and one of the things I
was talking to the police about this
morning in your local areas this concept
of hot spot policing and we're doing
that's what we're going to roll out far
more of including here in Essex I said
you're pleasing crime commissioner
nodding away and Hot Spot policing is
about exactly that it's about us knowing
what you just said because in every area
there's things like that that are
happening that we know about right and
when it comes to anti-social behavior
when it comes to things like shoplifting
in general there are patterns to it and
there are Pockets where it is more
prevalent and the use of hot spot
policing has been shown to work across
the UK but also abroad as well and we're
going to be doing more of that so we're
investing more in Hot Spot policing that
will hopefully address things like like
that the areas where we know it's
happening the times that we know it's
happening the people that we know are
typically committing it and Target our
resources on those people to make a
difference because I want you to be able
to go and do what you want to do which
is going to work hard make a living and
serve your customers and it's too hard
if your life is being disrupted by
criminals it's not acceptable believe
you me we want to clamp down on it and
part of this plan The Hot Spot policing
is going to help do that and then the
digital tool for people to report it
quickly and get it dealt with as well
all right good all right
um right who have we got yes ma'am
prime minister we work with vulnerable
youth across Essex many of them are
dropping out of school because they're
not coping either through learning
difficulties family problems and I think
that those are the young people we often
see falling into the edge of crime or
into criminal Behavior so my concern is
I'm I welcome what you're doing of
course because I think it's important
for Community safety however I do think
we need to look holistically at the
problem as well and try and get
underneath what is it that drives young
people into antisocial behavior and I
think community policing is huge you
know we've seen police officers who know
the family know the children know the
problems and get into that and I think
if we try and just go for the top I
think we're going to miss getting to
that really deepened causation of what's
driving this Behavior so definitely
learning disabilities dropping out of
school not having enough to do family
breakdown Etc seems to me to be one of
the biggest causes so